i have written like 60 songs like
it's like an insane amount of getting it
out anytime you go through some lives
like it's a such an awesome thing to
have that as an outlet regardless if
people hear it or not a lot of songs in
the vault but kelly clarkson admits
she's not ready to release them
revealing her divorce from brandon
blackstock has her nervous to share her
truth through music
it's been the hardest thing to navigate
it's
i've never had this difficult of a
project
kelly addressed the long delay between
projects on the chart show with brooke
reese she hasn't released an album of
new material since 2017's meaning of
[Music]
life and now she's explaining why to her
fans obviously everybody knows like a
huge divorce you know it went through
and and it's been like two years and not
easy with kids i'm just navigating like
what i'm comfortable with releasing
that's just like a hard thing to
navigate it's coming i just gotta get my
crap together
i just gotta figure out what i'm gonna
release
we'll be waiting but in the meantime
kelly is keeping fans fed on her daytime
talk show her daily covers of hit songs
known as kalyoke are a fan favorite
[Music]
[Applause]
and seems like this one resonated with
the singer after she filed for divorce
check out how she changed the lyrics
[Music]
billy eilish's original lyrics play out
as
cause
[Music]
you made me hate this
which has some speculating that kelly
relocating to la from tennessee to film
her talk show might have put a strain on
her marriage kelly first filed for
divorce nearly two years ago and she's
been teasing new music to e.t since i
have this record
that
we're working on that
is
is really great and it's very honest um
it's just there's just like a lot of
questions that i just have to answer
before releasing it and we know she's
still working on songs recently seeking
advice about songwriting from the chicks
who have also gone through divorces how
hard is that
to write so openly and so honest while
navigating children while navigating
people you know you're under a
microscope when you write falsely it
doesn't work it's transparent that
you're full of crap yeah you have to be
real oh great sorry i'm still blind
it's weird the more specific you are the
more it's universal to other people
while kelly shared a lot about her big
life changes she's kept some things
close to the vest when it comes to
ending her seven-year marriage telling
us she's still being cautious for the
sake of their kids river rose and
remington i care 100 more about my
children
than i do anything else on this planet
so um that's been the the hard thing of
like yes i'm willing to share my
experience but at the same time i have
to think
like what i say
is a domino effect into other people's
lives but she's not blaming her
ex-husband either nothing's wrong with
anybody it's just that's it happens and
that's why there's nothing to hide about
it in that sense um
you know it's just divorce is a really
shitty thing
but we all know some of the best art
comes out of pain so we can't wait to
hear what kelly's got to say just when
she's ready to share it well i have some
ideas for that coming up
[Music]
you